Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters. I want to show you how to use your TrueRife machine when you get it from us
So this video is going to go through some details. So this is using the TrueRifes computer and the program that I put and I put
Your program on the computer so I have the computer opened up you can see in this video and I already have the TrueRif
Generator plugged in of course you're going to take it out of the box
You're going to plug it into the wall. Preferably you're going to plug it into some sort of surge protector like I have here
That's plugged into a grouted outlet
And then you'll see on the front of the machine it has foot bath and bulb
Always you want to have it set to bulb when you're ready the bulb the foot bath is only what you're using the ion pro wave
I have the blog the bulb plugged in here red to red black to black
I'm not going to show you the bulb but plug in your bulb you never turn the machine on without the bulb plugged in
You always leave the bulb plugged in even when you're using the foot bath. I turn the power on here
And I plugged the machine via the USB cable which if something ever happens that cable you lose it
It's just a printer cable. So just get a good quality printer cable and you'll plug that into the back of the machine
Back here only goes in one way make sure you put it in the right way
And then that's plugged in to the USB port of the computer
Make sure you don't try to plug it into the SVG port plug it into the USB port on the computer either side
There's one on each side
But on this side I have the most plugged in yours came with the most two
You don't have to use the most you can use the little
Touchpad here personally. I don't like those things. So I'm going to use the most
How do you get to your program though? Look at the desktop. I arranged these icons so that they're viewed in a large format
So they're easier to view you go to your true rife program
This icon right here. So that's the icon for the true rife program
You're going to have to double click on that
So once you double click on that you'll open up the true rife program
And when the true rife program opens up then you can access your program. So it'll open up into this
Um, and now we want to get to your program. So I put a sheet of paper in your computer too
Easy step by step. How do you get to your program?
You click on open program and then you'll see all the programs that are in the true rife folder
But not your program in order to get to your program. You got to have to go to
The my documents this right here see this right there the my documents folder
Go to the my documents folder. Click on that and you'll see a folder that says true rife frequencies
In the true rife frequencies folder click on the icon the little yellow thing
There and you'll click on that and open up
A program that says a a and it'll have your name won't say my name to program
It'll have your name on there. So it'll say a a and your name
Then you'll open that and there's nothing here to open
So if I open that it's going to be blank because I just created that folder
But yours will now have all the programs. So let's go back to the home screen here open program
And we're in the home screen and let's open up one of these programs. Let's open up the
The depression seven day recovery program. So here it has the folders with these programs that are in that folder
Same thing with yours. You'll have a folder with your name on it
Then when you open it up you're going to have a Sunday night program, Monday night program Tuesday night program
Run those obviously as it says at night
So it'll usually say Sunday night bulb program. So you don't ever run it with the ion footpath
And they may be a folder on some of you that I put
Different footpath ion pro-way folders. Remember if you're going to run the ion pro-way
You have to switch it to back and you have to plug in the ion pro-way down here
And put the ion pro-way in water then follow the instructions on the course
For the ion pro-way you also got instructions original instructions from true rife
In your folder. So let's open up one of these programs
So we're going to click open on that program by double clicking on it
And then I will just click run up here to run the program
You should never touch anything in this section right here because in this section right here
Is the program itself?
And if you do something if you put your cursor in there and you start typing in that section you could actually
You know change the program you don't want to do that
Also people get hung up on the total time and the running time here. It's kind of fun to look at that
Don't look at that once you hit your program and you hit run for the evening program
Close the computer just close it and go to sleep the rife is very
powerful and it's said it don't frequencies if the bulb gets close to the
Close to the computer
It can actually throw off that time and you think oh it's not running it's not working
As long as the light is still coming from the bulb and remember sometimes it's going to be faint
Sometimes it's going to be real strong. Lots of times with the hammer tube
You can't even see the light coming from the bulb unless you're in a dark room
The program is running. How do you know the program's running
If you can't see the light coming from the bulb of course, I have a different bulb on here
But you can obviously see with this bulb
You'll see a little light flashing on the front of the trife
F122 generator see that little bulb power you know it's working
Of course, obviously troubleshoot if you're having any troubles
Make sure it's on bulb make sure it's plugged in correctly
Make sure you're plugged in to the computer. I tested your program
On my F122 before actually tested on your F122
That's why the cord is not bound together
Perfectly because I test yours before I send it out so everything works perfectly on it
So something happens. It's not working
Troubleshoot to make sure you're connected make sure your USB cord is connected here
Make sure it's connected to the back of the rife machine back here your powers on your bulb is on your
Switch to bulb here
And everything is going if you ever want to shut off your program you can just go right up here and click stop
right there
You've stopped the program now the the bulb is stopped. It's not lit anymore
You won't see any flashy light there and everything is working great
Now some people will say oh my gosh the bulb is getting really warm of course
It's getting warm it's producing frequency and it's producing energy and it's going to heat up
That's why there's a little teeny hole in the bulb to release some of that heat so that's all normal
So don't worry about that
Then if you're going to run a different program you open home again
You're back to the main screen with all the frequencies on the rife and you have to scroll through here
Because they're alphabetically there's about 2500 different programs out here for everything you can think of
But if you're dealing with cancer and I've written programs for you
Or whatever you're dealing with how do you get to go to the documents folder
Go to the true rife frequency click on the icon a little yellow thing double click on that you'll see your program
And there's you open that up. There's nothing in this one
But you'll see that your programs in there and you can run your programs
Have fun enjoying